[Música]
Sean bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro Cordero Paraguay enfrenta
elecciones generales este 30 de abril de
2023 esta nación que es la gran
desconocida de Sudamérica y
habitualmente sufre marginación en la
geopolítica regional llega a estos
comicios en un momento de cambio
político que puede sacar del poder al
partido Colorado tras décadas de
hegemonía casi ininterrumpida pero para
tener una visión de lo que es Paraguay y
su marco político es necesario
retroceder en la historia e indagar el
porqué de su aislamiento los conflictos
que lo han desangrado en este tiempo y
el origen del poder casi incontestable
de los Colorados
si hay una característica histórica que
Define a Paraguay es el aislacionismo y
el proteccionismo desde su independencia
de España en el año 1811 Paraguay
prácticamente no ha tenido relaciones
con sus vecinos y las pocas que tuvo
durante el siglo XIX fue en formas de
guerra la guerra más importante que
enfrentó fue contra Brasil Argentina y
Uruguay en la conocida como guerra de la
Triple Alianza entre 1864 y 1870 y ya ha
entrado El Siglo XX el conflicto más
importante que desarrolló fue la
conocida como guerra del Chaco contra
Bolivia entre 1932 y 1935 la guerra de
la Triple Alianza como comentábamos fue
un desastre sin paliativos para Paraguay
el gobierno de Francisco Solano López se
vio envuelto en un conflicto con dos
potencias grandes de la región como son
Brasil y Argentina por apoyar al partido
blanco en la guerra civil Uruguay y
rechazar la toma del poder de los
Colorados en esa nación una postura que
dejó en total medio millón de muertos de
los cuales 400.000 bajas eran de
Paraguay una cantidad muy alta además
Paraguay en esta guerra perdió casi la
mitad de su población según muchos
historiadores Y de esa mitad de la
población se estima que la Pérdida total
que hubo de paraguayos fue que el 90% de
los hombres falleció en combate un
desastre demográfico sin paliativos esta
guerra es la considerada como guerra más
Sangrienta de la historia de América
Latina y también hizo que hasta casi un
tercio del territorio paraguayo se
perdiera en estos combates como podemos
ver acá una buena parte del Norte de lo
que era entonces Paraguay pasó a Brasil
y buena parte del sur fue anexionado por
Argentina la nación comenzó a vivir un
periodo de inestabilidad y pobreza en el
que nunca hubo gobiernos estables y las
disputas entre los liberales y el
partido Colorado fueron constantes en
este tiempo varias guerras civiles a
inicios del siglo XX Además
empobrecieron más al país y el culmen
vino con la guerra por el Chaco contra
Bolivia un territorio sin una soberanía
Clara supuestamente rico en petróleo que
en realidad no lo era y que aunque
Paraguay consiguió controlarlo en gran
parte el derramamiento de sangre de
entre 30.000 y 50.000 paraguayos fue
catastrófico para el progreso de
Paraguay en estos conflictos un general
cercano al partido Colorado empezó a
ganar mucho protagonismo especialmente
por combatir a los partidos de izquierda
que habían Paraguay su nombre era
Alfredo stroessner
stroessner tomó el poder en 1954 y
comandó una dictadura que lo mantendría
por 35 años en el cargo más que ningún
otro mandatario en Sudamérica Este
dictador purgó de disidentes al partido
Colorado y lo utilizó junto al ejército
para crear un sistema de represión que
persiguió a decenas de miles de personas
la comisión de la verdad y Justicia
estima que en sus años en el poder hubo
423 asesinatos a disidentes casi 19.000
personas torturadas y más de 3.400 que
se vieron forzadas a partir al exilio
stroessner contó con el beneplácito de
Estados Unidos como sucedió con otras
dictaduras militares latinoamericanas
hasta que A mediados de los 80 la
situación económica empeoro y el
descontento aumentó la división entre
diversas facciones del partido Colorado
propició El golpe de estado del General
Andrés Rodríguez y el inicio de una
transición democrática
sin embargo este proceso se ha puesto en
cuestionamiento en muchas ocasiones ya
que fue iniciado por el mismo partido
Colorado y el ejército fieles Defensores
del estronato sin ir más lejos Rodríguez
fue la mano derecha de stroessner en la
dictadura por eso Durante los años
siguientes nunca se reparó a las
víctimas ni se persiguió a los
responsables de esta dictadura el
partido Colorado siguió en el poder a
pesar de las divisiones internas la más
sonada fue el conocido como marzo
paraguayo en 1999 cuando miles de
personas salieron a las calles a
protestar y causaron la dimisión del
presidente Raúl cubas después de que se
le inculpara de estar detrás del
asesinato del vicepresidente y su rival
político Luis María argaña
el cambio político no llegaría hasta el
año 2008 cuando una coalición de
izquierdas liderada por Fernando Lugo
consiguió una victoria histórica para
todo Paraguay ya que se convirtió en el
primer gobierno no Colorado en más de 60
años sin embargo este mandato no pudo
llegar a su fin debido a un
controvertido juicio político que sacó a
Lugo del poder en 2012 y cuyas
consecuencias fueron la expulsión de
Paraguay de organizaciones regionales
como unasur o mercosur tras esto el
poder volvió a ser del partido Colorado
de la mano de los presidentes Horacio
cartes y Mario abdo Benítez aunque las
recientes encuestas muestran que el
descontento hacia el partido que ha
monopolizado la política paraguaya en
las últimas décadas es alto y una
coalición de Centro izquierda liderada
por Efraín alegre podría dar la sorpresa
y derrotar a Santiago Peña el candidato
del partido Colorado el resultado lo
sabremos este 30 de abril con esto
concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]